[Music]
hi I'm bees in summer I'm a director of
engineering at target for external cloud
and containers as a service and I'm
gonna tell you today a little bit about
targets journey with kubernetes and J's
gonna tell it the story about kind of
how how it's gone as we've deployed that
into our stores so I'm going to talk
specifically about how target is using
kubernetes in our data centers in the
public cloud and in our stores across
the country I'm going to talk about how
target decided to bet on kubernetes and
kind of what our journey has been in our
data centers in Google and in Google
compute engine and in our stores and I'm
gonna tell you kind of what sorts of
challenges we ran into on those
different places and when and what we
learned as we went through that because
I think it's a similar story to what
most organizations would see but you
know this is how we've experienced it so
how did we get to using kubernetes in
the first place about I don't know four
or five years ago target started under
started to kind of try to adopt DevOps
and agile practices and part of that was
trying to move away from kind of a
traditional dev and ops model and to try
to empower the development teams to do
more of the the ops work and part of
that was by adopting configures code and
and to do that would target used a lot
of Chef and chef was great except for
all of these problems that we had with
it right I mean people used community
cookbooks that they didn't understand
and when they didn't work they didn't
know how to fix them they took a long
time to converge they when we were using
them in the public cloud
if a auto scaling group like a
know'd failed and it got replaced well
maybe one of those dependencies had
changed in the meantime then it didn't
work and people spent a huge amount of
time trying to make it work it was I
think I heard some team you know maybe
they were being hyperbolic but they
estimated that they spent 80% of their
time doing deployments and 20% of their
time actually you know delivering
software so about a little over two
years ago we started adopting spinnaker
and immutable deployments and we
provided basically the way that
immutable deployments work is that you
bots you provide we provided the teams a
base image which had you know met our
security requirements and had some
agents to do logging and stuff like that
and developers created an RPM file and
they knew exactly what they were
including they weren't like including
some community cookbook they'd install
an RPM from our from you know the from
our operating system they'd installed
their software that it put a config file
onto it maybe a templated config file
and the dependencies are all resolved at
Build time and builds took like five to
ten minutes but then when you want to go
spin up a new instance of your program
it took only a couple minutes but it was
limited to public clouds and took the
developer time the time it took them to
figure out how do I get their stuff
deployed from being about a month to
about a week and one of the biggest
problems that we had with it was that
you can't go out and buy an O'Reilly
book about the way that we combined all
of our tools together we used a lot of
hashing Corp tools we still do this is
how we do VM deployments we use a lot of
hashing Corp tools we use spinnaker we
use an elk stack and so the way that we
combined those together was unique to
target and see we had to write all of
our own documentation and teach you know
hundreds or thousands of developers how
how to use this stack oh and it was
limited to public clouds until target
added OpenStack support to spinnaker
along with Veritas we added support the
spinnaker which is now anyone can use
so now you could use it in the public
cloud and in the private cloud so
kubernetes why we why did we start using
kubernetes well we only provided the
spinnaker experience to our non commerce
digital clouds using public digital
teams using public clouds so only you
know a fairly small percentage of
targets developers were able to use
spinnaker in this immutable deployments
and so I I actually got up because I was
leading that team at the time and I gave
a presentation to everyone and anyone
who wanted to go in our technology
organization hundreds of people came and
I explained what we were doing and they
said when can I use it and I said I
don't know and so we started working on
making it so that we could do the deploy
into our OpenStack environment using
spinnaker to give it to them but the
other thing that we did was we started
standing up kubernetes in our data
center and that turned out to be
possibly an even bigger kind of change
and how people got stuff out there
then our OpenStack spinnaker work so in
the divot in the data centers developers
found the experience of using kubernetes
just irresistible it was so much better
than what they were doing was chef at
least you know based on how they'd been
trained on how to use chef I'm not
trying to knock chef but the the people
just found that they were able to
instead of spending 80 percent of their
time as some people said working on
deployments it became something they
spend a couple hours setting up and then
they basically didn't think about it
after that they just checked their stuff
and to get and it wound up in kubernetes
and they could move on and start paying
attention to making their application
work and even as we were struggling the
team that manages kubernetes is a target
with some performance problems which
I'll talk about in a little bit they
were still willing to put up with it
because it made their job that much
better application teams were much more
likely to build resilient applications
to because of the kind of constructs
that kubernetes has application teams
new you know we're steered towards
building things where you know we told
them hey you know that each pod you put
out there just assumed that it might get
killed at any time right make sure all
your stuff is stateless and as a results
given in comparison to our OpenStack
environment where I think that people
generally thought of things as living
there until they didn't unless something
went wrong we told them just just assume
it's gonna die and as a result they
built better applications and eventually
we worked out the performance problems
more or less and everyone lived happily
ever after but I've got a few more
details so here's an actual quote from a
developer he said that kubernetes
terrifies me to be honest
getting things running on mini cube took
so little time and energy that I don't
feel like I learned much about it am I
crazy to have this fear that it works I
have no idea why what happens when it
doesn't work and so that just kind of
shows the like you know when people
worked with Shaff it took them a long
time to or before that it took them a
long time to get stuff working and so
they felt like they you know kind of
understood how it worked and with
kubernetes they followed our directions
or they bought in a Riley book and they
followed those directions and when they
follow the directions it just worked so
kubernetes and our data centers so what
what challenges did we have we had we
had problems with ingress scaling I mean
one of the things that we ran into was
that as we were growing like everything
worked great before we had any
applications using it and then we would
start running into problems when we had
20 applications using it and then we'd
go and fix those problems and then we'd
have problems when we had 50
applications or 200 applications and you
know a lot of those things come from
things like there were performance
problems some of them you know we've
been doing kubernetes for a while some
of them have been fixed in newer
versions of kubernetes some of them are
just kind of inherent to the idea that
like if you use the nginx ingress
controller if you have thousands of pods
that are dynamically changing every time
it does that there's a 20,000 line
config file that nginx needs to reload
and nginx doesn't handle that perfectly
and so you know we've been going through
and kind of addressing these issues as
they came up for that so here are some
stats about how about targets use of
kubernetes in our data centers we have
as of when I pulled this a week or two
ago in our test clusters in the data
centers we have about 350 different
application teams deploying into
kubernetes we've got about 4,000 pods
running and it's not doing a whole lot
of traffic about 260 requests per second
in the production clusters there aren't
quite as many applications as some of
the application teams you know haven't
gotten to production yet about the same
number of pods and the reason for that
is that you know things are kind of a
larger scale in prod but maybe in tests
teams have multiple different
environments they might have dev and
stage or and perfect test environment
and whatever and the number of requests
per second is higher not as high as in
some of our other environments though so
we run kubernetes on GCP in fact my one
of our someone on our account team told
me the other day that the target is
actually the largest user of kubernetes
on GCP who's not using gke and I'll
explain a little bit why we're not using
GK but given that we're here it probably
doesn't surprise you that we're running
kubernetes on G on Google at all so some
stats about kubernetes running on google
compute we've only got 44 applications
there and 35 in prod and we've got about
a thousand pods but we handle a lot more
volume there and we use auto scaling
pretty well within that we've got about
much of target comm was running on
kubernetes last year through our peak
season and we had a peak of about 30,000
requests per second going into that
those kubernetes clusters and we're more
like 8,000 requests per second on a
typical day now with kind of organic
growth and whatever since then so what
sorts of problems did we run into in GCP
so there were some interesting things
that we ran into we still have the same
sorts of ingress problems when we're
talking from VMs in the kubernetes when
we're talking from our external load
balancers like a customer with a web
browser talking to us then we can use
the kubernetes integration with the
Google load balancers and all of those
problems go away
and but on the inside we are using
ingress controllers and we ran into the
same sorts of problems we had in the
data center and similarly you know we
can do a great job of failing over
between regions on the outside on the
inside some of the Google tools at least
when we started we're lacking to make
that easy to do so why not use gke so to
be clear I wrote this slide before this
conference and so back into 2017 when we
started the role based access control
within gke didn't have the features that
we needed it to have to meet target
security requirements and we told our
account team that and they're like oh we
really want to make this better but we
went ahead because we'd already been
doing it in the data center and that's
kind of my second point right we have we
have to have an on-prem solution so we
have to make a distribution of
kubernetes that works that integrates
well with target systems that does all
of these things and we have to do it in
the data center and we use these
immutable deployments where we make an
RPM and then we bake an image and then
we put we do that in the data center and
we do that in Google so it was pretty
easy for us to do it in Google and so we
just went ahead and deployed the same
stuff that we were doing in the data
center into Google and that worked
pretty well for us particularly given
that Google as I said that Google
actually open sources all of their
integrations that they have with Google
Cloud components and so a lot of the
things when Google comes up and like at
Google next last year and they say gke
can be like integrate with this thing
that Google well we got that too even
though we weren't using gke so I said I
made this slide before this
the conference our Google you know our
relationship with Google has been great
when we tell them you know they keep
saying hey why don't you use gke and we
say well butts because of this and this
and this and one of those things
probably the biggest one at this point
is well we need to run something in our
data center so we have to do that well
you know obviously with gke on-prem when
I get back I'm going to need to go
reevaluate what what to do you know you
know kind of medium term future whether
that's something that we want to adopt
now I'm gonna hand it off to Jay to talk
about our experience of putting
kubernetes in stores
hello everyone I am Jay John the shaker
and I work as a senior director of
technology at Target managing the
compute services what I'm here to talk
about is how we have implemented compute
on the edges Ethan talked about how we
used kubernetes as a compute platform of
choice both in our data centers and in
GCP what I plan to talk here about is
computer on the edges and how we use
kubernetes just to lay a context I just
want to understand the audience how many
of you kind of work for retailers ok
good so and I'm assuming physical
retailers do involve how many of you
kind of trying to solve each compute
problems ok great
probably some of you have solved it too
but I just wanted to understand the
content so so how I will go about doing
this is so I'll just for the folks or
probably not from the retail background
just a quick level set in terms of why
we need edge compute right so so that's
one part of it and then I will give a
cute background in terms of like the
history of how we did edge compute in
the stores and then kind of we'll get
into the bit of the detail about how did
we act
we implemented kubernetes across our
thousand eight hundred plus stores
thousand 829 to be exact so why be near
edge compute right so we started operate
thousand eight hundred physical stores
just like an e-commerce site need to run
24/7
we need our stores to be up and running
all the time the store systems need to
be up and running all the time so that
guests can actually come in and buy
stuff from the stores the if you think
about it either it is e-commerce or
physical stores and they guess to
actually comes in basically does the
same thing they browse items they put
item add items to the cart they go in
and they do checkout and what that means
for a physical store is we need to stock
shops so we use a handheld device called
my device to do to enable our team
members to actually stock shelves right
so these are productivity tools what I'm
trying to get to is a bunch of
productivity tools that our team members
use and many other retailers probably
know this stores are distributed they
are spread across geography right and
network outages happen but you can't
close the store if a network outage
happens so they need to operate
autonomous way when such things happen
and what that means is we need to have
the ability to work in a disconnected
fashion right so availability is a big
thing second part of it is
response time right so we pride
ourselves in our checkout experience and
if you take the other side of things
where our team members work using
productivity tools we want really quick
response time for them so that they are
not frustrated with the systems they use
and if you take the checkout example we
use a metric called scan to screen it's
basically says you know you've cashier
scans an item it should actually show up
on the cash register
in 250 milliseconds let's say and that's
sounds great but if you think about once
you scan a barcode what all things need
to happen before it actually shows up on
the screen it need to fetch item
information and it need to calculate the
price it needs to incorporate the
promotion's it need to calculate tags
before it actually shows up there so
I'll need to happen in within 250
milliseconds so we probably have a
different kind of issue to solve from a
response standpoint right so those are
two reasons why we probably need
computer on the edge because we just
can't afford to take the round trip back
to cloud or tornado center it's a bit of
history how we operated computer in the
stores if you look at five years and
back we bundle things right application
developers build things and they get
bundled together tested most times by a
separate team there is a deployment team
that actually did the deployment there
is a huge orchestration around it
because these deployments are huge and
they cost a store outage right so and
that's disruptive to the stores so you
need to find out what's a good time to
deploy this and that required a whole
team of people to actually manage it how
many other retailers this sounds
familiar so so we were there so and then
around you know 2015 2016 2016 is time
period of course we started embracing
open source we have the Linux server
available in the store and so people
were able to start building
micro-service is great right and then of
course we use you know team started
using shop cook books to start deploying
right it's great and some of the
challenges like ethan mentioned earlier
related to how people build cookbooks
and how it becomes complicated it
it's started becoming challenging for
the teams they were able to deploy it
fairly successfully but it's more like
80% right
you still need to login to a sufficient
set of stores to fix things
it soon became evident that teams were
spending like sometimes up to 70% of
their Dow the developers time in
actually fixing things so that it will
work in the stores so so deployment was
like a nightmare so so we need so we
needed two things from this right so we
needed immutable images and we needed
the ability to safely deploy them to the
store so and what I mean by that is we
don't want this mess about like when you
talked about thousand eight hundred
stores we need something that we are
guaranteed it will work and and
containers were a great concept right
and and it let developers do that it
also brought in some other a benefit
which is very profound we were suddenly
able to build things once and be able to
deploy in the cloud for our e-commerce
and then we were able to deploy it in
the stores for our checkout lanes so
that was performed so immutable images
and then we were we wanted to deploy
with no downtime one of the things that
I really wanted the team to be able to
accomplish was we wandered developers to
be able to safely deploy during their
time even so what that what that means
is no downtime right so kubernetes let
us do all that so great then that's the
reason why we want kubernetes so people
agreed on that now with that said there
are challenges how are we going to
implement kubernetes across thousand
eight hundred stores and how are you
going to manage it if it takes stores
itself it's pretty small alright so we
don't have like a vast compute cloud
infrastructure there we have basically
in most of the stores
beyblades with a shared storage so so
it's not huge we have of course stores
go offline so it can lose power it can
lose Network so it needs to be able to
operate by itself in some sort of like
an autonomous fashion then there are
other complications how are we going to
if we do an implementation how are we
going to manage deployment across
thousand eight hundred and twenty nine
stores how are we able to monitor it how
are we able to budget the resources
appropriately those are all challenges
so the team went about solving it and
what they did was they build what we
call as a system called you nemetrix
so Unimatrix access like this
centralized system for developers to
interact with this fleet of kubernetes
clusters which thousand eight hundred
and twenty nine clusters and it will
interact with this fleet of thousand 829
kubernetes clusters in an a synchronous
way and it implemented kubernetes api
spec and what that meant for the
developers were that they can interact
with it as if they were interacting with
a big vast kubernetes cluster and at the
same time i don't know how many people
actually attended John and Goldman's
spinnaker talk we use pinnacle for
deployment yes and spinnaker natively
supports kubernetes so we didn't have to
do anything there it just kind of
seamlessly fit right in
Unimatrix does primarily two things it
it fetches the desired states that that
gets applied to it and then and actually
distributes it off to the fleet of
kubernetes clusters and then it at rebel
intervals fetches back the actual state
so that worked really well
we could let these kubernetes clusters
work kind of autonomous but for
developers kind of acted like a single
kubernetes cluster we solved the problem
of developers being able to build stuff
and then just kind of deploy it and it's
not as simple right like you don't build
things and just deploy 2829 stores right
so so there are nuances around it so we
need to build more features right so
generally what happens is developers
will build an application or a feature
they want to deploy to one store in
certain cases if it's a proof-of-concept
they want to really send it to like a
subset of stores our stores itself what
kind of grouped into regions and then we
have different format of stores small
format large format and we also have
specialized things in the stores like
you know some have Starbucks some have
liquor that they sell so we needed some
way to group it so that people can
actually deploy them to this set of
groups so we leveraged kubernetes
namespaces to do that and I don't know
who came up which developer came up with
the concept of using animal names but
they actually use animal names to group
stores so beetle is one store it's
exactly one store probably a store in
Minneapolis [ __ ] Rapids store and if it
is valorous it is got two hundred and
ninety nine stores so and what in
essence happens is V store of course
these namespaces desired states at HQ
right on at the central system the
beauty about this is stores can go and
of course work autonomously and if it
goes down it can come back up and gets
the desired state and it will eventually
kind of get into the state it need to be
the magical thing is if you if we build
a new store we just need to add it to
the group it will automatically start
working it will identify which
applications it need to
run it will download them it will run it
we don't need to do anything it's almost
like magic so so we solve that problem
of building groups and providing
developers that ability to run
applications in these groups so to speak
so that's where we are right so this is
a real snapshot of our production it's
been occur where an application in this
case called promo engine being deployed
to our stores so they deployed it to the
group called Tiger which group of 600
stores you can actually see that they're
running version 7 and it is all green
promotion engine is something that our
cash registers use so it's pretty
critical for our stores now so this is
all working so where are we now
so we started this journey early last
year and we onboard our first customers
around peak season last year now we are
in all 80 129 stores there are three
nodes in each store so fifty four five
thousand four hundred and sixty six
nodes are running we have close to 200
thousand parts running in production
across our chain and it's growing really
right that's the state we are in
developers so so the goals we set out to
accomplish
being able to deploy memorable images
being able to safely deploy teams can
now deploy safely software to the stores
during their time when the store is
actually working in a safe fashion and
they can do it across our chain that
story of kubernetes
in stores thank you
[Music]